okay very exciting we have increased the
duration of the daily show by 10% now
this might not sound like some big
victory but a year ago we increased the
duration of the show 10% we've done it
again the way we've done this is by
cutting the amount of breaks from the
broadcast show we have this hour show on
radio TV it can't go longer than an hour
there were a commercial radio shows that
in an hour have 38 minutes of content
that used to be us we've expanded expand
that expanded expanded we've now added
another 10% to the show making it nearly
a full hour show and that is fantastic
you might have noticed this week that
we're able to look at some stories in
more depth we're not gonna cram more
into the show it's just gonna let us do
more depth for the shows for the stories
that we're already doing I think it's a
really great thing we are also adding a
daily written digest of the show a lot
of people have written to me and said
you know David I prefer to read stuff I
like your perspectives I like the show
but it's easier for me to read on the
sub when people took the subway to work
in those days I like reading on the
subway or whatever we are going to be
turning our daily newsletter into a sort
of written digest of the show you can
sign up for what will become this in the
next couple of weeks on my website at
david pakman.com just sign up for the
newsletter you'll get all of it it's all
great stuff you can also sign up for
that at david pakman.com it will also
provide a new way to support the show
but it's also going to be free for
everybody that wants it for free really
really great stuff I am thinking of this
virus phase for the show I am thinking
of it as the process of a caterpillar
becoming a butterfly okay I use this
analogy on the bonus show yesterday we
were a caterpillar going into
coronavirus during coronavirus we are in
the chrysalis stage I'm going back to
like third grade science class we are
now in the chrysalis stage and my goal
is that we will come out of coronavirus
re-emerging as a butterfly less orange
of Cour
than a monarch I don't want to be like
Donald Trump but as a butterfly with a
lot of great things and a better program
and all of these things so exciting
stuff and very very good news looking
forward to all of it once we get past
this difficult time